[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen viel
Fußball hat im Sport Christian guten
Abend und bundesweit wurden heute die
Trillerpfeifen rausgeholt
Protest gegen die Pleite vielen
Krankenhäusern geht es finanziell
schlecht die Belegschaft macht heute
lautstark darauf aufmerksam
Konfrontation in New York im when
Sicherheitsrat scheitert Russland mit
dem Versuch eine Rede des ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski gleich zu Beginn zu
verhindern
und Auftaktniederlage der Fußball
Champions League Borussia Dortmund
verliert gegen mit Favorit Paris
Saint-Germain
[Musik]
Geld klagen die Krankenhäuser und
befürchten das Kliniken schließen müssen
für heute hatten sie daher zu einem
bundesweiten Protesttag aufgerufen der
Bund helfe bereits mit
Milliardenbeträgen so
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
schauen wir uns die Lage genauer an
im Jahr 2010 gab es noch
2064 Krankenhäuser in Deutschland
seitdem geht die Zahl kontinuierlich
zurück
2021 waren es noch
1887 also knapp neun Prozent weniger die
Zahl der Betten ging im selben Zeitraum
um etwa 4% zurück einen Entwicklung die
sich aktuell beschleunigt war die
Krankenhausgesellschaft über die
Proteste Dominik Müller Russell
große Sorgen macht sich
Geschäftsführerin Maut beste um ihr Haus
deshalb ist sie heute vor dem
Düsseldorfer Landtag gezogen sie leitet
das Klinikum Gütersloh doch die Ausgaben
laufen völlig aus dem Rudern Beispiel
Energiekosten
Operationssäle müssen gekühlt
Bettenhäuser geheizt medizinische Geräte
betrieben werden ihr Verbrauch ist fast
so hoch wie der einer Kleinstadt ihre
Stromrechnung hat sich dieses Jahr
verdoppelt oder Personalkosten 4
Millionen Euro muss ihre Klinik nun
zusätzlich ausgeben für gestiegene
Gehälter 40 Kliniken haben in diesem
Jahr bereits Insolvenz angemeldet laut
Krankenhausgesellschaft sie alle
fürchten das gleiche Schicksal
wir merken einfach wir kommen mit dem
Geld vorne und hinten nicht aus wir
haben keine Chance es zu kompensieren
und wir laufen in eine ungeregelte
Insolvenzwelle die bedeutet dass wir das
was wir für selbstverständlich halten
nämlich eine gute Versorgung damit nicht
mehr gewährleistet sein wird die
Kliniken fordern Unterstützung von den
Ländern und vor allem vom Bund der
Bundesgesundheitsminister verweist auf
die krankenhausreform die ab 2025 die
Finanzierung auf solidere Füße stellen
soll außerdem helfe der Bund etwa bei
Energiekosten schon vorher in der
Übergangsphase wird der Bund noch mal
bezahlen 200 Milliarden fließen jetzt
Pflegekosten werden wir beschleunigt
bezahlen die Länder sind jetzt auch mal
gefragt sie könnten jetzt mal ihre
Investitionskosten bezahlen die sie seit
10 Jahren zur Hälfte schuldig sind
schnelle Hilfen fordern sie im Klinikum
Gütersloh angesichts der Zahlen die Lage
sein beispiellos ich habe eine solche
Entwicklung und eine solche Dramatik in
25 Jahren Krankenhaus noch nicht erlebt
mit vier Millionen Euro Defizit rechnen
Sie in Gütersloh dieses Jahr mit 7
Millionen schon im nächsten wenn nicht
bald etwas passiert befürchten sie
wirtschaftlich nicht zu überleben
zu den UN in New York sehr aufmerksam
wird dort auf die offene Sitzung des
mächtigen Sicherheitsrates geschaut der
ukrainische Präsident selenski sprach
dort vor etwa einer Stunde und forderte
eine umfassendere Form des
Sicherheitsrates mehr dazu von Claudia
Bates
unter dem riesigen Wandbild des Friedens
nimmt er Platz doch wo wurde mir
silenski bringt den russischen
Angriffskrieg hier in den Sicherheitsrat
dem russischen Botschafter bei den
Vereinten Nationen sitzt der direkt
gegenüber Außenminister lavrofis
zunächst nicht erschienen der russische
Vertreter beschwert sich darüber dass
Präsident selenski hier zuerst sprechen
darf der albanische Präsident der
Sitzung findet klare Worte
dafür gibt es eine Lösung wenn Sie
zustimmen stoppen sie den Krieg und
Präsident selenski wird nicht das Wort
ergreifen
selensky wollte hier friedensvorschläge
unterbreiten und drängt dafür auf eine
Reform der Vereinten Nationen die UNO
habe Russland als einzige Quelle des
Krieges erkannt aber für Russland habe
das nichts verändert sein Vetorecht habe
die Vereinten Nationen in eine Sackgasse
getrieben
mit einer zwei Drittel Mehrheit die die
internationale Gemeinschaft
widerspiegelt mit Asien Afrika Europa
Nord und Südamerika und der Pazifik
Region mit dieser qualifizierten
Mehrheit sollte das Veto überstimmt
werden können
auch andere Redner sehen im Vetorecht
das größte Problem
wir ermutigen Anstrengungen dass
Vetorecht einzuschränken dann sollte ein
Moratorium eingesetzt werden das
schließlich dazu führt dass das
Vetorecht mit der Zeit ganz abgeschafft
wird
Präsident selensky hat nach seiner Rede
die Vereinten Nationen verlassen zum
direkten Zusammentreffen mit dem
russischen Außenminister wird es wohl
nicht kommen
wir haben gerade redet der russische
Außenminister MRT wissen wie äußert sich
lavrov
ist gewissermaßen zum Gegenangriff
übergegangen er behauptet dass Russland
tatsächlich für die Grundprinzipien der
Vereinten Nationen Eintritt für
territoriale Integrität und Souveränität
und dreht dann den Spieß rum und
behauptet dass der besten allen voran
die USA tatsächlich in den vergangenen
Jahren diese Grundprinzipien immer nur
selektiv anwenden wenn sie ihnen passen
dass sich die USA beispielsweise
eingemischt hätten in die inneren
Angelegenheiten der Ukraine und
Russlands in den vergangenen Jahren und
das alles was danach kam im Grunde
genommen nur eine Folge dessen ist Labor
zeigt sich also in jeder Weise
uneinsichtig und das zeigt glaube ich
ein Stück weit wie wichtig das ist was
selenski gesagt hat nämlich dass es am
Ende darauf ankommt dass man das
Vetorecht von einzelnen Staaten die sich
als Aggressoren betätigen brechen kann
aber das würde natürlich auch heißen
dass die Vereinigten Staaten und China
dem am Ende zustimmen müssten dass sie
ja Vetorecht verlieren in Konfliktfällen
und das ist derzeit nicht in Sicht am
Ende müsste die Generalversammlung der
Vereinten Nationen darüber befinden
danke schön für diese Einordnung
verheerende Stürme wie sie zum Beispiel
immer wieder die Philippinen heimsuchen
sind auch eine Folge der Klimakrise wie
ist die Entwicklung zu einer immer
heißeren Erdatmosphäre noch aufzuhalten
Antworten auf diese Frage suchten die UN
nun am Rande der Generalversammlung in
New York dabei waren führende
vertreter:innen von Staaten und Regionen
aber auch Organisationen Unternehmen
Marco berichtet
jetzt Sanjo ist von weit her nach New
York gekommen der Philippino will Druck
machen damit die Staats- und
Regierungschefs Vorankommen beim
Klimaschutz
perfekt ich erwarte dass sie ernsthaft
über die Zukunft nachdenken ich erwarte
dass sie an ihre Kinder denken damit sie
irgendwann mal in deren Augen schauen
und sagen können dass sie als Führende
der Welt ihr Bestes gegeben haben
seine Heimat die Philippinen werden
immer wieder hart getroffen von Stürmen
Fluten oder dörren sowie viele Länder im
globalen Süden in New York jetzt neue
Zusagen Deutschland will seinen Beitrag
zum grünen Klima vor der armen Ländern
helfen soll aufstocken
Germany Deutschland will 2 Milliarden
Euro bei Steuern eine Steigerung um 500
Millionen Euro im Vergleich zur letzten
Aufstockung solide Finanzzusagen sind
die notwendige Basis um auf der nächsten
Klimakonferenz voran zu kommen
noch reichen die bisherigen Ambitionen
der Welt nicht für die Klimaziele von
Paris der Ausstoß der Treibhausgase
nimmt weiter zu werden alle Klimaziele
der Länder auch um gesetzt biegt sich
die Kurve wohl bald nach unten aber um
das angestrebte 1,5 Grad Limit für die
Erderwärmung zu erreichen müsste der
Ausstoß weit drastischer sinken jetzt
Sanjo jedenfalls hört sehr genau hin in
New York und er wird es wohl auch Ende
des Jahres wieder tun bei der Welt
Klimakonferenz in Dubai
in den vergangenen Monaten sind deutlich
mehr geflüchtete nach Italien und auch
nach Deutschland gekommen jetzt sieht
Bundespräsident Steinmeier beide Länder
an der Belastungsgrenze bei einem
Treffen mit seinem italienischen
Amtskollegen matarella auf Sizilien
forderte Steinmeier eine offene Debatte
in Deutschland die müsse das Ziel haben
die geflüchteten Zahlen zu reduzieren
ohne europäische Regeln ließen sich die
migrationsprobleme aber nicht lösen
besonders schnell surfen kann man mit
dem sogenannten 5g Mobilfunknetz viele
Komponenten darin stammen jedoch von den
chinesischen Firmen Huawei und zde in
der Bundesregierung gibt es daher die
Sorge vor einer zu großen Abhängigkeit
von China und das China gegebenenfalls
Handyverbindung ausspionieren oder einen
Blackout verursachen könnte innerhalb
der Bundesregierung gibt es nun Pläne
den Einbau chinesischer Komponenten im
5g-netz zu begrenzen dort ist Färber
ein 5g-netz schnell ausgebaut mit Hilfe
von preisgünstiger chinesischer Technik
damit dürfte bald Schluss sein wenn es
nach dem Bundesinnenministerium geht der
Einfluss chinesischer Hersteller wie
Huawei auf Netze in Deutschland auf
kritische Infrastruktur sei zu stark
für mich ist wichtig und das ist auch
Bestandteil der nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie der Bundesregierung
und auch der china-strategie dass wir
möglichst Abhängigkeiten vermeiden und
Sicherheitsrisiken minimieren das
Innenministerium könnte verbieten
chinesische Technik ab 2026 im Kernnetz
zu verbauen und was jetzt schon aus
China verbaut wurde soll weitgehend
wieder raus Antennen und Masten müssten
erneuert werden nicht machbar in der
Kürze sagt die Telekom mit Blick auf
Genehmigungsverfahren verfügbare
Kapazitäten bei alternativen Lieferanten
verfügbare Kapazitäten bei
Bauunternehmen und den von Kundschaft
und Politik gewünschten weiteren
mobilfunkausbau ist ein Zieldatum für
den Austausch bis 2026 durchaus
realitätsfern
sehen in der Koalition sind die Pläne
umstritten das Verbot chinesischer
Technik könnte den Ausbau des 5g-netzes
verlangsamen und teurer machen fürchtet
die FDP unsere Position ist das ist beim
5g-ausbau ja schon jetzt ein
sehr hohe Standard und strenge
Vorschriften bezüglich des Einsatzes
kritischer Komponenten gibt und wir
diesen sehr differenzierten Ansatz auch
als Durchfall ist sinnvoll erachten wie
weiter mit 5g ohne Abhängigkeit von
China nächste Woche will die Ampel nun
beraten
zweimal ist Innenministerin Feser nicht
im Innenausschuss des Bundestages
erschienen als es um die Affäre
schönbogen ging heute stand sie dort nun
Räder und Antworten die Opposition wirft
dir vor den Chef des Bundesamtes für
Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik zu
Unrecht versetzt zu haben zudem soll sie
den
verfassungsschutzinstrumentalisiert
haben um Erkundungen über Arne schönbum
anzustellen beides wie ist die
Ministerin zurück mehr von Las Bohnsack
es war im Oktober des letzten Jahres als
die Innenministerin den damaligen
Präsidenten des Bundesamtes für
Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik
schön Boom abrief allerdings nicht wegen
eines kritischen fernsehbeitrags sondern
wegen gravierender fachlicher
Differenzen wie sie sagt mein Hauptziel
war es Schaden vom BSI als Behörde
abzuwenden diese wichtige
Sicherheitsbehörde
muss in der Öffentlichkeit als
hundertprozentig integer und
vertrauenswürdig gelten für ihr
Fernbleiben in den letzten
innenausschusssitzungen hat sich die
Ministerin entschuldigt doch mit ihren
Antworten gibt sich die Union nicht
zufrieden wir haben ausführlich gefragt
sie hat
geantwortet aber sie hat bei weitem
nicht alle Fragen beantwortet und sie
hat teilweise auch die Widersprüche
nicht aufgehoben sondern teilweise sogar
verstärkt in den Verdacht der Union die
Innenministerin habe den
verfassungsschutzinstrumentalisiert um
Erkundigungen über schönboom anstellen
zu lassen dementiert dessen Chef nach
Oktober 22 hat es weder von Frau
Ministerin Feser noch von anderen
Mitarbeitenden im Bundesministerium des
Innern noch mal anfragen in diese
Richtung anders Bundesamt gegeben die
ampelparteien sehen die Innenministerin
entlastet wurde hier ein deutscher
Nachrichtendienst
rechtswidrig missbraucht
und dieser Vorwurf ist ausgeräumt worden
der hessische Wahlkampf ist längst im
Bundestag angekommen die Berliner
Oppositionsparteien dürften ein
Interesse daran haben das Thema
politisch noch nicht für beendet zu
erklären
Lehrkräfte in Deutschland beobachten
immer häufiger Anzeichen von Kinderarmut
in ihren Klassen das ist das Ergebnis
seiner Umfrage die heute zum
Weltkindertag von der
Robert-Bosch-Stiftung vorgestellt wurde
ein Drittel der Lehrkräfte berichtet die
Kinder würden sich häufiger Sorgen um
die finanzielle Situation der Eltern
machen in sozial benachteiligten
Gegenden ist es sogar fast die Hälfte
dass die Kinder unzureichende
Schulmaterial haben beobachten 37
Prozent im benachteiligten lagen sogar
fast zwei Drittel
Gewerkschaften und Verbraucherschützer
appellieren die preisbremsen für Gas und
Strom sollen über das Jahresende hinaus
verlängert werden so könnten
Privathaushalte auch im kommenden Winter
vor Energie-
gestern noch war die Sorge groß vor
einem neuen Krieg um Bergkarabach heute
nun sollen sich die dortige armenische
Führung und Aserbaidschan auf eine
Feuerpause verständigt haben noch am
Morgen wurde ihre Region und die
Hauptstadt der panagiert von mehreren
Explosionen erschüttert laut des
aserbianischen aserbaidianischen
Verteidigungsministeriums haben die
Armenien
Armin Körper wie belastbar ist diese
Einigung
ich denke nicht besonders belastbar
Aserbaidschan bezeichnet zwar heute die
Berga bachfrage als gelöst und spricht
davon das Gebiet in das eigene
Territorium eingliedern zu wollen es
sind aber viel zu viele Fragen offen zum
Beispiel was mit der Zivilbevölkerung
dort passieren soll werden die
davonlaufen werden die vertrieben oder
werden die sich vielleicht zur Wehr
setzen all das ist unklar Russland
feiert sich als friedensvermittler hat
aber de facto allen Forderungen
Aserbaidschans zugestimmt und sein
eigentlichen Verbündeten Armenien damit
fallen gelassen interessant ist das vor
wenigen Stunden Meldungen kam das aber
inzwischenfall gegeben Mann russischer
Militär Konvoi sein Berg Karabach
beschossen worden war der Aufklärung
setzte Russland ausschließlich auf
Aserbaidschan von Armenien ist gar keine
Rede mehr also Fakt ist heute Abend das
Aserbaidschan Präsident Ali auf den
richtigen Zeitpunkt gefunden hat wo die
Partner Armeniens abhängig sind von
Aserbaidschan und das betrifft auch die
Europäische Union der von der
EU-Kommission hört man heute abend man
sei eben abhängig von Gas aus
Aserbaidschan danke schön für diese
Einordnung im Körper
einer der größten privaten
wohnungskonzerne in Deutschland vonovia
verschiebt den geplanten Bau von 60.000
Wohnungen wegen gestiegener Baukosten
ein weiterer Rückschlag für die Ziele
der Bundesregierung sie strebt wegen der
Wohnungsnot in jährlichen Bau von
400.000 neuen Einheiten an
heftig wird über das Pestizid Glyphosat
gestritten nach einem Vorschlag der
EU-Kommission könnte der
Unkrautvernichter 10 weitere Jahre
eingesetzt werden
Umweltschutzorganisationen sehen in
Glyphosat Gefahren für Menschen und
Umwelt der Hersteller Bayer bestreitet
das entschieden über die Empfehlung der
EU-Kommission müssen nun die eu-
mehr als 30 Mal war Charles als Prinz
offiziell in Frankreich jetzt kommt er
als König mit gemahlen Camilla zum
dreitägigen Staatsbesuch Präsident
macron und seine Frau empfingen das
royale Paar mit einer Zeremonie auf den
champs-
und vom König soll Königsklasse Fußball
Champions League Christian mit
Enttäuschung und Freude eben nicht alles
ganz so glatt nach den durchwachsenden
Leistungen in der Bundesliga ist
Borussia Dortmund mit einer Niederlage
in die neue Champions League Saison
gestartet 0:2 bei Paris Saint-Germain
die Dortmunder mit einer verunsicherten
Vorstellung im prinzenparkstadium
mit Glück entgeht der BVB in gelb in der
ersten Hälfte einem Rückstand vitina
trifft den Pfosten ja das Ergebnis war
noch offen zu Halbzeit aber das Spiel
war nicht wirklich offen wir haben
einfach den den Mut vermissen lassen ein
umstrittener Handel Elfmeter unter
Mitwirkung von Niklas süle kurz nach der
Pause verhilft Paris mit Kilian mbappé
zur Führung der frühere Dortmunder Acher
fakimi sorgt nach gut einer Stunde für
den 20 entstand
[Applaus]
wir haben gut verteidigt vor allem in
der ersten Halbzeit aber mit dem Ball
war es einfach nicht gut genug dortmund
muss jetzt gegen den AC Mailand und
Newcastle United Punkten
für RB Leipzig 13:1 beim
Schweizermeister Young Boys Bern bereits
in der dritten Minute die Führung durch
Mohammed Sima kann nach dem Ausgleich
für Bern erhöht zunächst aber Schlager
mit diesem tollen Distanzschuss in der
73 Minute und wenn er mir in der
Nachspielzeit zum 3:1 entstanden
ja die anderen beiden deutschen Vereine
spielen heute Union Berlin bereits bei
Real Madrid und die Bayern empfangen
nachher Manchester United alle
Höhepunkte 23 Uhr im Sportstudio UEFA
Champions League
Stefan Kunz ist nach knapp zwei Jahren
als Nationaltrainer der Türkei entlassen
worden bereits am Sonntag wurde über
seinen aus spekuliert am Nachmittag kam
die offizielle Bestätigung des
türkischen Verbands Kunst war auch als
neuer Bundestrainer gehandelt worden
Streik beendet und dennoch keine Ruhe
bei Spaniens fußballweltmeisterinnen
zwei der 23 Nationalspielerinnen sind
nicht bereit die neuen Vereinbarungen
mitzutragen sie werden bei den nations
League Partien in Schweden und gegen die
Schweiz nicht dabei sein den beiden
Profis vom FC Barcelona Drohnen aber
keine Sanktionen der spanische Verband
will die tiefgreifenden strukturellen
Veränderungen morgen unterzeichnen
sollen sofort umgesetzt werden
ja und ich habe noch eine traurige
Meldung aus der Leichtathletik rutfuchs
ist in Jena gestorben die zweimalige
Olympiasiegerinnen Speerwerfen gewann
ihr erstes Gold in München 72 vier Jahre
später wiederholte sie diesen Triumph in
Montreal sie war als erste Frau den
schwer weiter als 60 Meter gut Fuchs
wurde 76 Jahre alt und sie bleibt
unvergessen
die Lottozahlen von heute die
Gewinnzahlen lauten drei
1821 24 33 42 Superzahl ist die 2
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
vier Sonnenschein und Wärme aber auch
Regen ist beim Wetter angesagt mehr dazu
gleich von essentielli das heute journal
können Sie um 21:45 Uhr sehen mit Dunja
Hayali schönen Abend noch
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter über den Atlantik
ist der ehemalige Hurrican Lee zu uns
gewandert hat hier die britischen Inseln
erreicht und sie sehen hier eine
Kaltfront die dazugehört die erreicht
uns morgen im Tagesverlauf zieht relativ
langsam bringt Regen und einige Gewitter
mit und vorher kommt ihr richtig warme
Luft vor allem in den Osten Deutschlands
und da kratzen wir an der 30 Grad Marke
in der Nacht gibt's im Süden Nebel sonst
klartis häufig auf bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von 9 Grad im Vogtland und
18 Grad ganz im Westen Deutschlands
morgen dann erst einmal überall
Sonnenschein aber dann ziehen hier
Wolken auf im Westen Schauer und
einzelne Gewitter sind dabei das ganze
verlagert sich Richtung abends dann in
die Mitte Deutschlands sonst im Osten
und dem Südosten vier Sonnenschein bei
Temperaturen bis 29 Grad hier Richtung
Berlin ansonsten 20 Grad ganz im Westen
Richtung Eifel el ja wechselhaft geht's
in den nächsten Tagen weiter und vor
allem Kühler 14 bis 21 Grad am Freitag
Samstag immer noch Regen dabei und
Sonntag wird es aber allmählich Trockner
und damit ein schöner Abend